Hi, boys. This is how to succeed in AQA.
A level chemistry No. 1 tip.
I'm gonna tell you the best Youtubers out there.
Elliot Rinstall,
Allery chemistry.
Those are for, like,
the content,
so when you're making your notes,
flash cards, whatever.
And for the final exam,
when you come to, like,
practicing exam technique. And, um,
they also got cover topics.
So A level cookbook and exams made easy.
Second piece of advice is get the CGP, um,
AQA book, because it's got the best, um,
reaction mechanism map out there.
And basically you wanna, um,
write it from memory over and over again until, like,
you can just replicate it without looking at the book.
That means in the exam,
they ask, any reaction or any, like,
reaction name,
and you just write out,
and it's just free marks.
Third tip for the curly arrow mechanisms,
just write out.
Yeah. Once again,
it's so much repetition. Chemistry.
Just write out on a few papers, um,
over and over again
until it's literally just like drawing a picture,
right? And it's.
It'll just get you three marks in the exam.
And my final tip would be,
um, just persevere with it.
Like, it's a tricky subject,
but for me at least,
I was struggling throughout the whole,
like, 2 years,
and I find it, like,
really complicated and stuff,
but, like, towards the end,
it just really clicks
once you put the time and effort into
memorizing everything.
And trying to get the theory behind why things happen.
Um, it should be a doable subject.
So good luck, boys.